on the number of people that get
infected or pass it on
and the preliminary results have been
gathered inside
government now that data is not ready to
be published formally yet so i don't
think we're going to hear about it
at the press conference it'd be
interesting to see if any of the
journalists ask boris johnson
or the two scientists what they think
about it
i think they're waiting for a little bit
more data just to check that that 60-65
figure is accurate and also to look at
the impact on hospital emissions
but uh that preliminary data inside
government uh
does look incredibly encouraging it
challenges some of the
um kind of more cautious approach in the
european union
particularly around the astrazeneca
virus you'll remember uh president
uh emmanuel macron questioning its
efficacy for older people
no we understand the study uh says in
its draft form uh it works well
uh and it works well for all age ranges
uh some
confirmation of this by the way today
from the world health organization
uh which has formerly uh suggested that
the vaccines
work for all age ranges and that uh
put those two bits of data together and
that's uh incredibly
uh strong and good news there is a small
rider to that
however which is that uh the better the
vaccine news the
tougher the political dilemma for the
prime minister
uh you may have thought that he sounded
a bit cautious during prime minister's
questions just take his answer for
instance on schools where he talked
about
um on the 22nd him setting out at the
stages that schools will be reopening
uh rather suggesting that they're not
all going to open
reopen in one block primary and
secondary
altogether um so he's clearly at the
moment
sounding like he's sounding cautious uh
if there's strong vaccines news then
that could encourage uh some of the tory
uh backbenchers to go harder on him
like charles walker was earlier today
when he said we've got a vaccine
we can't delay reopening um sam it's
mark austin here now uh just coming up
to five o'clock or it is five o'clock
waiting uh for the prime minister um
he may be a minister too late and just
on that point you're making i mean is
boris johnson becoming
almost a victim of his success with the
vaccine rollout because he will get more
people
like charles walker putting pressure on
him to
to lift the lock down and soon look i
think
um if you were to ask boris johnson that
in private he might say well it's a
better problem to have than the one
six months ago where there wasn't a
vaccine that was incredibly successful
on the
uh on the horizon but there's no doubt
uh that yes there are uh problems and
tensions arising from the fact that the
vaccine rollout has ended up being
uh far better and far swifter both in
terms of its rollout in this country
possibly the largest fastest uh
proportion of people vaccinated
uh of a large uh country in the world uh
and also of its efficacy
just six months ago people thought that
you'd need a combination of vaccines
they could only be given to certain
sections of the population uh and that
they would need to change every year now
um oh and it sounds like they're here
somewhat early
good afternoon and thanks for joining us
it's five weeks since we set ourselves
the target
of vaccinating almost 50 million of the
most vulnerable people
in the country and the aim was and
is clear to everyone by offering the
prospect of
protection from kobe to everyone 17 and
over
to all frontline nhs and care staff
to older care home residents and staff
and to all those
who are clinically extremely vulnerable
we can do the most
the fastest to reduce the incidence of
use the incidence of
death and serious illness and with less
than a week to go
until the target date of monday the 15th
there's no doubt we have made great
strides
with just over 30 million people now
vaccinated
in our united kingdom including one in
four adults in
england over 90 percent of everyone over
75
and over 90 of eligible residents
of care homes for the elderly but
that still leaves nearly two million
people a population roughly
twice the size of birmingham that we
still hope to reach
and there are people across the country
who for one reason
or another haven't yet taken up their
offer so now is the moment to do it
wherever you are you won't be moving
about 10 miles away
from a vaccination center so go online
or get someone
to help you or simply pick up the phone
and call
119 and let me appeal particularly to
the fantastic social care workers that
we
all rely on to look after our relatives
our parents
are grandparents if you haven't received
a letter
please contact your employer and fix it
up
and let me stress that these vaccines
are safe
and effective and it was good to see the
world health organization today
confirm its support for the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
for using everyone over the age of 18
and obviously
everyone over 65 and also
supporting the 12-week interval between
the two doses
indeed they say the longer interval
provides greater
protection and the reason i make this
appeal
today to for people to come forward in
those groups and get vaccinated
is not so we hit some a numerical
target but to save lives uh prevent
serious illness and so the whole country
can take another step on the
long and hard road back to normality
and as the data comes in i'll be saying
more about that
including setting out the road map over
the next
two weeks i think the people of this
country absolutely understand the
importance
of protecting the most vulnerable first
and that's what we are doing
and if we can keep the pace up and keep
the supplies of
vaccine up we hope to reach everyone in
cohorts one to nine
by the end of april and i want to thank
all those involved
for their heroic efforts the doctors the
nurses military medics
local authorities transport planners
warehouse
operatives delivery drivers countless
volunteers
often working through the night or even
digging out snowed in
vaccination centers like the community
effort at allwoodley
medical center in leeds last saturday so
gps
nurses and their teams could deliver
200 doses that day and i want to thank
the millions of people who have received
their vaccinations and
with cases still high and the
pressure on our nhs still
severe i want finally to thank everyone
all of you who are continuing to follow
the rules and i urge you once again
to stay at home protect the nhs and save
lives
thank you very much i'm not going to ask
patrick
to do the slides yes thank you can have
the first slide please
this shows the number of people testing
positive for uh
covert 19 in the uk from september
through to
today and what you can see is that this
peak that we've had in january is now
coming down
uh coming down to much lower numbers
today the number was 13 013 people
testing positive so these are people
coming through the testing system
and you can see that there is a good
decrease but numbers still remain high
next slide please a
more unbiased way of looking at this is
the ons
survey which takes a sample of people
from across
england in the community and what you
can say
see here and the pinkish line is when
restrictions were
introduced the lockdown and you can see
the numbers are coming down
and these are old data because it gets
updated every week
and they look backwards a bit so i'd
expect this to come down further
when we see the next set of data and
come down further again thereafter
so in terms of the number of cases
things are definitely heading in the
right direction
and that is trending also of course in
terms of hospital admissions which are
coming down
as well next slide please
and this shows the reduction in the
number of people in hospital so hospital
admissions have come down and the number
of people
in hospital has come down as well you
can see here the dotted line shows the
number of people that were in hospital
with the first peak so we're still above
the first peak numbers
but it's clearly coming down and i want
to take this opportunity to just say
thank you to everybody because it's
because people have stuck
to the lockdown rules and the difficult
rules that we have to follow in order to
get this to come down
this is reducing uh to in the way that
we see
and also of course a huge thank you to
my friends and colleagues in the nhs for
all the enormous work they've done
to look after this number of people so
hospital
admissions and hospital numbers coming
down and this
is also translating into a reduction in
deaths next slide please
and you can see here the um seven day
average
shown in the line and then the
individual days which which dot around a
bit depending on reporting
but you can see the seven day average
coming down
again deaths coming down as
hospitalizations come down as well
so all of the numbers are trending in
the right direction
uh coming down quite well because of the
effects of the
of the lockdown and here the deaths are
now below the first peak average and
coming down but they've still got a long
way to go
and i expect them to take some weeks to
come right down
final slide please and as the prime
minister has said the vaccination
program
is going very well and over 13 million
people have been
vaccinated thank you thanks very much
patrick let's go to questions from
members of the public kathy from
huddersfield
two priority groups in the daily
infection figures
if so by how much and if not why not
thank you
i think that's an incr an incredibly
important uh question
kathy um and i as i
as i as i told everybody a few weeks ago
this is one of the key things that we
were going to be
looking at as we uh make our plans for
the the road map in in in a couple of uh
weeks time um and we'll be following the
data very closely but i think i'd really
better go to
uh to patrick for um
an appreciation of what we're actually
seeing so far because at the moment
uh although we're seeing uh reductions
in deaths and we're seeing the
uh control of the virus it seems pretty
hard to me
uh to see actual uh impact of the
uh of the vaccination uh program uh
on on those on those numbers yet but i'm
told that
uh we wouldn't be necessarily uh be
seeing it
yet but but patrick over to you well it
take it takes
two or three weeks for the effect of the
first dose of vaccine to really start
kicking in in terms of immunity a little
longer
towards three weeks or possibly longer
in in the oldest groups
and then of course it takes time for
people to catch infections and for that
to show up
so it's not surprising that we're not
getting all of the data through yet
um if you look at israel there's
beginning to see some
data there suggesting um quite a
significant effect
and we will be able to analyze our data
over the next uh
next couple of weeks to start seeing um
the effect and i think it's important
not to keep looking
uh too early because these are
complicated uh figures to look at but we
would expect to see a reduction
first of all in um severe disease and
and probably in
in the deaths and and also in in
infection rates and and that's what
we're looking at
and we'll see data as i say within the
next couple of weeks i hope
thanks very much uh kathy let's james
from huxbridge
with the government expanding the
availability of lateral flow tests to
businesses with more than 50 employees
are there any plans to use similar
schemes to allow for the opening of
weddings and other events with a similar
number of guests
thank you james i'm i'm a massive
enthusiast for the advantages of
uh of lateral flow uh testing and a
daily
uh testing uh it's getting ever more uh
sophisticated uh there are tests that
you can do now
that uh don't require uh that you just
require a slivery
uh test they're faster than the ones
which which involves swab
up the nose and uh and so on uh but
these will really come into their own i
think as we uh as we
get the vaccination program uh really uh
you know going down the cohorts uh and
as we as we start to
uh to be able to unlock in the way that
i hope to to
set out in the next uh in the next
couple of weeks so the the answer to
your
to your question james is we do want uh
eventually of course we want
uh weddings and other such events to uh
to go ahead
as a result of the uh of the vaccination
the overall programming the overall
reduction of disease and lateral flow
testing we think will be of continuing
benefit uh to uh businesses and to
events of all kinds as an additional
safeguard but patrick perhaps you'd like
to
comment on that nothing really to add i
mean i think we need to wait for numbers
to come down before we start thinking
about
how to keep things open and obviously
get more vaccinations out and then
natural flow tests clearly have a place
in terms of picking up infections that
otherwise you wouldn't detect
thank you very much and laura koonsburg
bbc
uh thank you very much prime minister
should members of the public be booking
summer holidays or not
whether at home or abroad because the
transport secretary this morning warned
people against booking anything
at all and sir patrick if i may
how concerned are you about the
potential of the variant that's been
picked up in bristol where there have
been 14 cases in that city already and
suggestions it might be
more transmissible than some of the
other variants around
thanks laura well as you know as
everybody knows it's currently
illegal to go on holiday
that's the state of play at the moment
we're looking at the data
every day on monday we'll be able to say
a little bit more about where we are in
terms of the
uh the jcvi one to four group and uh we
hope and
uh whether where the data is then and
in the week of the 22nd as i said we'll
be setting out
uh the the road map and uh that is uh
the best i can i can give there's
not a an awful uh long delay now between
now and the
and the 22nd uh but i hope uh that we'll
be able to give some more
clarity uh to people then laura
in in terms of the variance we're seeing
the same variance or some of the same
things in various popping up all over
the world
and that's what you'd expect there are
some variants the virus likes to have
because it gives it some sort of
advantage and the advantages that
variations may give include increased
transmissibility
or increased severity and potentially
for some
immune differences which means that the
body recognizes it differently from an
old variant those are the three things
that one
worries about um the common variant
that's now in the uk
that started was first detected in in
kent um
does transmit more and perhaps is more
severe as i've described before
but it doesn't seem to cause enough of
an immune shift to worry about that in
terms of vaccine so the vaccines work
really well against that
so the first message is that you know
for all of the
massive uh of the virus out there it's
getting vaccinated which is important
and making sure that we everybody who's
eligible to get a vaccine goes out and
gets vaccinated
really critical the bristol variant has
got one of the
changes that the south african variants
got as well and again it's one that the
virus likes to try and get so it's not
surprising it's happened and it will
happen elsewhere as well
and um in getting that variant it does
make it slightly more likely
to look different to the immune system
so we need to watch out for it we need
to measure it
to keep on top of it and need to keep
testing um the vaccine effects in the
in this situation but the very key thing
the thing that we have to do is get
numbers down the lower you get numbers
the lower the chance of getting more
mutations
thank you uh tom clark itv news oh
it didn't answer the question
thanks very much uh public health
england has confirmed to us
today that what looked like really
positive data for
of on vaccine efficacy in the real world
in the uk
vaccine rollout are you encouraged by
how well the vaccine
appears to be working in that early data
and to simpatric violence if i may
given the great progress we're making on
vaccination and encouraging results
are you becoming concerned that the
politicians you advise might be tempted
to uh maybe resist your advice to be
very measured and slow
in how we lift lockdown restrictions
well
thank you very much thomas i think you
may uh may guess
there's no one more tempted to be
encouraged uh by
uh data than the than me but uh i've got
to be uh honest with you i've looked at
the
to the the data i've seen and
scrutinized it with my
layman's eye and so far as i said in
answer to
to kathy from uh from huddersfield uh
you know
uh yes we're getting the the numbers
down
uh but uh can i see uh results that i
think are directly attributable
to the rollout of the vaccine uh
although i'm sure that that will
happen soon tom i i can't say that i can
see them
yet and that's that's my uh my honest
answer at the moment but uh
so it's great that public health england
have published some encouraging data but
that's
that's how it seems to me at present but
patrick again yeah i just want to wait a
bit longer
until we see the full data i mean we
need to get data that comes through that
we can really understand
analyze and be sure of what's happening
say
encouraging results from israel coming
through the clinical trials are very
clear about the efficacy of these
vaccines so you'd expect all this to
happen i think we should wait and look
at this properly and not try and
second guess as we go along in in terms
of the
speed of change it's worth remembering
that even with very high vaccine
uptake and it's great to see so many
people have come forward and been
vaccinated
there's still a large number of people
who aren't vaccinated and there will be
a significant number of people in
high-risk groups who aren't yet
vaccinated because
they either haven't had an opportunity
to they can't take it for some other
reason or they haven't come forward
and those people remain at risk and so
it's important
that we go cautiously in opening up in
order to be able to measure the effects
and one of the things that's really
crucial in this is to
get enough information to know the
trajectory we're on
and not jump ahead of it because we're
very high levels
and that can take off very quickly so i
think caution
is important as we go into opening
things up and
measuring is important and data is
what's going to be important
um the virus isn't going to be
particularly interested in dates
absolutely and i think what uh what
business is going
up and down the country are going to
want is a cautious and measured
approach that is that is pragmatic and
and uh one that we don't have to
retreat form or or reverse andy bells
channel five news no thank you um
prime minister the um travel
organization ayata says they've been
talking to the government about
developing a travel
app uh can you confirm if the
government's been talking to them about
developing this and
is it not quite a good idea to develop
an app whereby people's
uh vaccination status their test status
could be recorded
and could that be a way to unlock travel
in the summer and one question to you
sir patrick the prime minister says he's
a big fan of lateral flow tests
are you absolutely satisfied that those
tests are as good as they need to be
to perform the function they're being
asked to do now
sorry uh andy on on uh
the travel app we're looking at all
sorts of things
that we may wish to to do in the in the
months ahead of course
that's right to do you'd expect us to be
talking to uh to travel firms about
all kinds of options but the top
priority
now is to drive forward that vaccination
program for
everyone uh to give everyone that's
vulnerable
uh the highest possible level of uh
protection and then keep on working
down the age group so we give everybody
in the country the protection
uh that they need or that we can give
with the science available to us and
then
and that's the way we want to to get
back to to normality that's our
our priority uh and but when we're in
that
uh different world which i hope will be
as you know obviously as soon as
possible then all kinds of apps and all
kinds of possibilities
will be open to us and the lateral flow
tests um
a really important part of our toolkit
and um
if you compare natural flow tests to pcr
you'll get more positives with pcr
because pcr is very very sensitive you
can
pick up very low levels of virus which
may not even be infectious it may just
be low levels there so
pcr will always pick up more than
lateral flow
lateral flow tests are good at picking
up people with high viral load who are
most infectious
um they will pick up if you use them in
situations where you otherwise wouldn't
pick up anybody of course they're useful
to pick up the people that you would
have missed by definition because you're
not testing
and what they're not is 100 guarantee
that you haven't got it
and that's important i mean they they
they will pick up positives
and that allows you to deal with people
who are positive and also allow
people to isolate and they will not
guarantee
that you haven't got it but they will
reduce substantially the chance and so
they have to be used in the right
circumstances and that's what public
health england have advised and i think
in those circumstances
they are absolutely the right thing to
do yeah i think i think the
key thing about lateral flow tests is
they're going to be part of the
of the mix and they're really a very
important part of the of the mix but
what they fundamentally
are useful are doing is telling you
whether you're likely to be infectious
uh much more accurately than they can
tell you whether you're actually
uh infected uh as it were so they they
do have a very clear
uh use case but it's in conjunction with
everything
we're doing and the priority is
obviously uh vaccination
mikey smith the mirror
my prime minister a couple of quick ones
for you um
first of all you didn't really answer
laura's question about summer holiday so
i thought i'd let you have another go
um there's a bit of confusion between
your ministers about whether people
should book summer holidays
um you said it fairly recently that
you're optimistic about
it um is your family planning to get
away this summer
and what's your message for members of
the public who are desperate to get away
from all this
and secondly in july last year
government scientists told you that
what their prediction of the worst case
scenario was uh for the spread of the
virus and the run-up to winter
newly released documents uh that the
government held back for six months
uh show they also told you that the
worst case
scenario was avoidable if you followed
their advice
they suggested you not rush to reopen
schools and universities that you not
plan to relax
rules over christmas and that you keep
people working from home wherever
possible
and in each of those cases you did not
follow that advice
um only to reverse course when it made
things worse
and by november before the new variants
emerged we were in the worst case
scenario that was predicted in july
two weeks ago you stood on that spot and
you told grieving families you'd done
everything you could but don't these
documents suggest that that isn't true
well mikey first of all on your your
question about
uh the summer holidays i really repeat
what i said to
to laura i'm afraid it is just uh too
early for people to
uh be certain about uh what we'll be
able to do
this summer and we hope to be able to
say more in the week of the 22nd as i've
said when
more data comes in more more crucial
data about
uh the rollout of the vaccine program
and how it's working on
on us all mikey so i'm afraid i
understand why people want to make
plans and now but we're just going to
have to be a little bit uh a bit more
a bit more patient and on your your
second point well
there's been scientific advice of all
kinds uh throughout the
uh the pandemic and uh what i can
tell you is that as soon as we became
aware of the
uh of the new variant on the 18th of
december which substantially changed the
uh position we acted uh decisively in
the way that
in the way that we did but uh there have
been people scientists who have called
for
uh no lockdown uh scientists who have
called
uh for uh uh for a complete lockdown
uh throughout uh they've been brutally
uh difficult
decisions and uh we have done our best
as i've
as i've said before to take in into all
our decisions
in the interests of of public health and
protecting
the public a mesa hall from the express
who i'm afraid i left out last night
mesa
uh
[Music]
matey mesa you need to unmute
thank you i'm sorry about that can you
hear me yes uh
uh thank you very much prime minister um
sir patrick um
what is the latest scientific evidence
saying about the effects of uh vaccines
on people who've already had coronavirus
does it double up with the antibodies
and give you an extra layer of
protection
and what would your message be to anyone
who might think that i've had the virus
i don't need the jab and um prime
minister you talked today in the commons
about
booster jabs in the autumn um
does that mean we're going to see the
the infrastructure the mass vaccination
centers and so on
around for some time and given the
concern about uh new variants
is it possible that some covert
restrictions may have to stay in force
until the over fifties have been given
that booster jab
you wanna go personal around your bodies
yeah sure um um
if you've had coronavirus we know that
most people get antibodies
and and uh um get some protection from
it
really important to get the vaccine as
well i mean the vaccine will give
another boost on top of that
um highly likely that you get a very
good immune response overall
in that situation and so um it's not a
reason to
avoid vaccination i'd encourage
everybody to come forward for
vaccination
mesa we don't see any evidence at the
moment
to say that the virus the vaccines
don't have a beneficial effect against
uh all the variants so
uh it's it's likely
that uh all the vaccines have at least
some uh beneficial effect
on all variants but the way we're
thinking at the moment
you'll have heard jonathan van tan say
this the other the other night is that
as new variants appear it will be
more useful uh than ever to have
vaccines that can combat
all variants and yes i certainly think
we need to
be getting ready for a world in which we
do have
uh booster jabs uh against uh
new variants uh in the autumn uh but uh
what we
what we want to do and maybe maybe
beyond and we should start to think
about it as a
as a a flu jab uh something that
that elderly or vulnerable people make
sure they have
every year and and i've no doubt that
the vaccines will get better and better
at
uh being able to cover for all uh for
all variants
but the the plan at the moment is is to
continue to accelerate the rollout of uh
the
the present vaccines for for all groups
and uh
as i said just now uh we're aiming for
all uh jcvi
groups uh one to nine by the end of
april
okay uh thank you very much wait we've
got one last question from
uh nigel pretties from pharmaceutical
journey
thank you prime minister community
pharmacies
have been a vital lifeline for patients
delivering medication
and remaining open to provide health
advice and support during the pandemic
and of course providing coverage
vaccinations
but they have yet to see their
additional costs during the pandemic
reimbursed and we're seeing hundreds of
high street branches close due to
financial problems exacerbated by covert
19.
when are you going to reimburse
pharmacies for their additional costs
during the pandemic
and how many pharmacies are you happy to
see close
before the government does anything
about it
well nigel i don't want to see any
pharmacies close i think pharmacies
provide a
community pharmacies high street
pharmacies provide an
absolutely outstanding resource for our
country
and its and its healthcare needs and i'm
particularly grateful to pharmacies
now for what they're doing as part of
the vaccine effort
the hundreds of pharmacies up and down
the country are already
distributing vaccines very effectively
and we think that they can play a very
important role
in helping us to get vaccines into the
arms of
people who may be harder to to reach we
think pharmacies can play a really
really important role
uh people trust pharmacies they know
where they are they can find them
uh the the the people who work in the
staff are
well informed helpful it's a it's a very
very good environment to get
a a lot of good things done to protect
the public so
on your point about reimbursement i
would want to make sure that they're
reimbursed
uh as soon as possible they they play a
vital role
in helping us to to fight the pandemic
and many many other
public health needs anything you want to
add to that
patrick no well thank you all very much
see you next time thank you
prime minister there that is one in four
adults he said in england has received a
first dose of the vaccine that's 13
million
in all we have made great strides he
said but still
need to reach many people with the
vaccine
he said it was good to see the world
health organization approved the
astrazeneca
vaccine and also the gap between doses
on summer holidays either here or abroad
not much to say he said it was
currently illegal to go on holiday and
he would say more on february the 22nd
um on vacti vaccine effectiveness he
said they just were waiting
simply for more data on that sir patrick
valen said the number of people testing
positive is coming down dramatically he
said but it is imperative
we go cautiously in opening up
uh let's speak to our deputy political
editor
sam coats who was listening to all of
that and sam what struck me were
words used by the prime minister like
cautious measured
pragmatic and i think he said at one
stage we want an approach that we don't
have to retreat from
absolutely mark you do get the sense
that the government is trying to pitch
roll
uh warn its backbenchers perhaps that uh
when he stands up on
february the 22nd the prime minister is
not going to be able to give a timetable
that very rapidly takes life completely
back to normal
he's under increasing pressure as the
news on the vaccines gets better and
better to do so
but the prime minister making absolutely
clear that
he doesn't want to do anything now that
means that he opens up and then has to
retrench and it's
that idea i think that the prime
minister has got fixed in his mind this
government has
opened up and closed down and opened up
and closed down several times
and there's a huge political as well as
a huge economic cost
to do that so the prime minister
signaling he wants to go
cautiously in order to make sure uh the
infection rates are low as we
uh go through the stages of reopening
the country again
now that will frustrate people like
charles walker who we heard
on sky earlier who's saying with
infection rates low and having a vaccine
they'll always be a reason to put off
reopening but nevertheless the prime
minister seems set on this course
wouldn't engage with questions on
booking a summer holiday
now couple of attempts by a journalist
some frustration as his
failure to engage with the question but
he did say he'd talk a little bit more
about that on the 22nd so it's
perhaps not all over yet for the uh
summer holiday
um the single most important thing uh
was he refused to engage with the
positive
uh vaccine information that's been
collected at the moment by public health
england by his own side
uh he the prime minister pointed to
strong results from the world health
organization who
today uh said that they're following
britain in recommending the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine to be given eight to
twelve weeks apart and said a longer gap
asset was associated with greating
greater vaccine uh efficacy and will
reach more people so
he does like the good news coming out of
the vaccine but he's not ready to roll
out the british good news yet because
as patrick valden said they still want
more data yeah and sam you mentioned
charles walker there who was speaking to
sky news a little earlier let's just
have a listen to what he said and then
we'll come back to you we have the
vaccines we were told
they were the way out of this so we
vaccinate the population but you're
still in lockdown people are going to
start scratching their heads
and start wondering what on earth is
this this all about what the government
is doing now is bordering on the very
dangerous to be perfectly honest
it is robbing people of hope it is
robbing people something to look forward
to and it is very
very stupid and very very short-sighted
now i don't hold the prime minister
responsible for this
but i do hold his secretaries of state
responsible for this
and he needs to rein them in very very
quickly
so he doesn't blame the prime minister
for that sort of thing but he does
very critical of matt hancock i mean
will the prime minister be listening
to that sort of uh um criticism well it
depends how
widespread and how strong it was charles
walker seemed to
have been particularly angry over the
government's suggestion that it will
jail for ten years people who lie about
what countries they've been to
and whether or not they've been to a red
zone country one of those 33 with one of
the new variants
suggesting that were you really going to
jail for a decade a young person is that
fair is that right
and blaming grant chaps for suggesting
you can't book holidays matt hancock for
his jailing policy
and scattergun approach of criticism but
charles walker does represent a strand
of thinking in the conservative party
that is nervous about the caution
they're currently hearing from
government scientists in particular and
occasionally from the prime minister
there is this coveted recovery group it
can expand into a number that really can
cause quite a lot of difficulty
uh for the prime minister mark carper uh
the former chief whip
is uh the chair of it and he has been
worried
about some of the cautious signals
coming out of it so the simple answer to
your question is yes there comes a point
where too many tory mps
reject an overly cautious approach and
the prime minister has to take notice
okay sam thank you very much indeed
this is the newshour with me mark austin
coming up we will be live in washington
where president trump's
second